okay everybody welcome to the Tuesday
evening a class mastering the middle
game your game it's in a very important
part of the game it's when you finished
opening you sort of make all the natural
moves pieces are out and then you need
to find a plan which is difficult a lot
of times you're know where to start from
you know improve the placement of the
pieces go for a direct attack what to do
trade some pieces so it's you know it's
not easy basically so let's take a look
at this game because I feel like this
game we got into an equal position out
of the opening and then later slowly I
try to improve my position middle game
by finding the better moves slowly
slowly and managed to get a win in this
game my opponent is a very strong
grandmaster julio Becerra
this was play this game was played in
2014 we played a match between each
other it was in Lawrence Kansas so yeah
it's a good player and it's very strong
with white so ii 4 e 6 so we have which
opening french defense and I play this
opening for 27 years so you know I have
some good results you didn't serve me
very well in the last year's
championship I lost the last two games
but overall it's been you know it's been
a you know pretty solid twin solid
opening for me it served me well and
nine of six so 93 he plays what is the
name of this line this is the classical
so 93 is the classical so that's what
happened Knight f6 there are a couple of
different ways to play here you can play
Bishop before the winner where you can
play Knight of six good pressure only
four you can play D takes e4 you can
play the Rubinstein we can play this
Knight f6 mode oh he has two options he
can play e5 attacking my knight or he
can play Bishop g5
so he goes Bishop g5 d takes e4 Knight
takes e4 Knight bt7 Knight f6
and now what move did I play here I know
this is part of the opening still but I
want to give you a chance to try to find
the best move here
you could go Bishop e7 yeah that's
possible what else we have u b6 here but
then Bishop b5 here you little bit risky
because b6 is a very risky move Bishop
b5 comes in and you're getting all
pinned up enough the pin is very
annoying so what you need to try to do
here is on pin the pin okay so how about
we try to question the bishop and ask a
attacking him to see what is he going to
do h6 questioning the bishop now let's
check and now he's got three options
which page for Bishop e3 Bishop takes f6
all three of them are playable but they
lead to different type of positions so
that we should be three very principled
move very principled move to try to see
what to do you know like in this
position so now 95 was played before I
play this myself against couple of very
high-profile players in saqqara nakamura
ATM back row a few other names all 2700
players so tends to be a little bit
risky though you're moving the same
piece twice while you're not developed
so I didn't play that anymore so I
switched a little bit more solid reply
here so from here on I'm going to ask
you to find the remaining moves of this
game let's see if you can find logical
good moves slowly improve the position
slowly and try to defeat this very
strong grandmaster first what's the
first priority here it's to do what to
castle perfect so we identify the first
priority here is to develop our piece to
castle which piece is on the way here
that is prevent
that's from kozilek you excellent in
game yes developing Bishop to on good
active square and now getting ready to
Castle Bishop d3 b6 what is the biggest
problem in a French defense guys you've
heard me you heard me saying this many
times probably light-square bishop so
when we get a chance we won't activate
this Bishop or perhaps to trade it so
with a b6 with idea Bishop to with a v6
with idea Bishop e7 95 is activating his
Knight trying to put some pressure
we should be salmon there's a little
issue because we should be 5 check
castle oh sorry actually we should be so
apparently apparently I was not too
worried about check check is although
wasting more time so we can just move
the King can't a lot of time is wasted
she goes queenie to castle castle
yes visual visa to prevent 96 yeah it's
possible you might be able to do that
now castle and what to do here we need
to try to attack him to put pressure
he is feeling very strong he is feeling
very strong in the center here so try to
put as much pressure as possible yes
excellent job that's part of the plan in
this Rubinstein validation that I'm
playing okay
he transpose this show to the Rubenstein
enough if you didn't take only four
right away so the c5 is important move
to attack it if he takes by the way this
is a problem for him because we take the
knight yes he does have this check which
could look a little scary you know for a
moment but no problem we take he takes
out a queen we take and at the end of
the day we have a lot of lot of lot of
development so that's the nuts the
possibilities we have to try to do okay
any questions all right so that's why we
that's why tactically we could make this
work
this c5 move so he cannot take it yes
right here oh yeah are you going to do
that really
with a rook here King here it could be
not a problem it could be a suicide look
at that now look at the position of your
king that's what we call in chess what
we call when you take a pawn like that
and you lose
what kind of pawn is it we have a nice
term for that or is it all excellent yes
so you understand double poison pawn a
lot of times people take a pawn they
think they're going to win later but
that's the poison pot understand you'll
never take that kind of pawns guys never
take that kind of funds okay
so you will see 5 equals 9 c4
Grandmaster Becerra is putting pressure
on my knight the prior of my bishop I'm
sorry I've removed the bishop he is
going to take on c5 and it's just going
to be difficult a little bit position
for me now what should I do here I need
a good move here
excellent NIDA fire activating and
putting pressure on the bishop detects
e5
now what should we do here how should we
capture it
that takes first
very risky no Queen takes c3 and some
x-rays could happen there bit risky
should takes your Bishop is always
vulnerable so you just want to take back
with your bishop now it goes Bishop
takes e5 pawn takes okay my pawn is a
little bit weak but I also have the open
B file I can activate my pieces what we
call this dynamic dynamic equality right
now going on but I like my chances
because at some point I can maybe seize
the initiative but at the moment it's
dynamic equality I mean neither for
Health Initiative
that's equal I know yeah yeah yeah yeah
so this is like a pure end do it like
this is already middle game right here
so like I need this much basically from
here round we're on our own like this 94
this was all middle game right now so
and here I played you know he doesn't he
does have a little bit of pressure I
have to admit like this 96 is coming
Bishop before oh it seems like you know
you might even be tiny bit better here
it might be he might be so the next move
is very important to play because I want
to make sure my position is not going to
be loose you know and like I have bishop
that out it's unprotected 96 come play
with the temple and I done like that
always make sure your pieces are
protected in one word you have
consolidation okay so now can you
combine a good developing move and
protect the loose piece that you have
it's all it's a useful move logical move
excellent choice yes rook to b8 now he
goes rook he1 rook he1 white is
completing the development on the other
hand what should I do
it looks like I don't have that many
useful moves in this position activate
the Queen well that would be nice that
would be nice to activate the Queen but
but I didn't have that many active
squares unfortunately like you know this
knife is quite good you know it stops
everything for text that's why he went
Queen e7 you know it looks a little bit
scary but this is the right place for
them for the Queen indeed so now I have
flexibility now to move my knight I can
when I before I can do some other things
so that gives me a flexibility now he
goes Bishop b4 try to put ton of
pressure on me now threatening to take
only efore Bishop takes rook takes c4 a
lot of a lot of pressure now what should
we do here how we should try to untangle
this okay you know this pressure he has
on me if you make a bad move you can
lose a piece first we have to identify
the threat which is Bishop takes d5
takes rook c5 then we have to take some
measures against it I was thinking maybe
equalized first and then see what
happens but when I equalize then I
slowly start to improve improve and then
there was opportunities so I managed to
actually win this game strike and win it
if you if you will worry about the Queen
where is the Treasury Queens with me
sighs chat I mean quick yeah but if I
was going to do I could probably do it
at once you know by immediately playing
Queen
that's a blunder remember I mentioned
that boom boom boom yeah you can take my
this clinician you take with this
dropping a crook here so you gotta watch
out that's pressure that is a pressure
yeah there are drops of awkward it's not
good anyway
so which piece is his strongest piece
that has been annoying for the past five
six moves the most annoying piece and an
active piece that he has the trip or the
blockers or the blocker of your palm AHA
that is the most annoying piece so what
can we do against it huh
of course not be six when opponent has a
superior piece compared to yours right
what do you want to do trade it off very
simple his PC superior versus yours
trade it off absolutely trade it off now
it goes ninety five he doesn't want to
just straight up this is the moment
we're heading made a strategic error you
know he was still trying to push perhaps
to try to play for the win or something
but instead he should have just you know
you know be happy just exchange the
pieces and so it's it's equal position
so I think 95 is a strategical oddity
slight error it should take on v6 and
you know it's just probably going to be
a draw okay because this is a lowland
posture I know but at least you'll see
now what happened he's not got trapped a
little bit on the side of the board
because we know that night on the rim is
damn and grim right yeah but what I'm
saying was it looks like he is still
pressing but he's the one who is going
to be in trouble gentlemen I took so we
are happy right we solved the problem of
the light square bishop
he took back and now what is the last
piece that wants to join the action this
one first look here we're keeping that
for that skirt if you play this move now
why I didn't play this move who notice
the idea why I didn't play this no it
looks the most natural move here right
but I want to complete my development in
a bit different way
why I didn't play this one who can see
the tactic oh yes
excellent visualization and that's the
LPD or loose piece drop off right on b8
very good very good very good job yeah
so he went here perhaps you should go
back Knight c4 I think this was already
getting pretty serious you know so he
played c4 actually blocked it and now
get the last piece into the game and now
he was okay I was leading the match at
the moment so he was down by two so he
had to perhaps try to do something so
maybe that's why he's then oneexchange
nice otherwise you just down by two so
he went back here but here I already
like block to be honest because his king
is little bit loose you know and I like
to do something so now now I play the
following move rook d4 exclamation mark
because if he takes we take he takes
what is the idea check one two huh how
about that loose piece and again don't
put your pieces on the rim he does have
this move it's not completely losing now
check we take if he takes here we go
check he goes away we just simply take
it so 94 so it has to take rook takes
you for check he has to go here anyway
he cannot go away because
so he has to go here and you will just
yeah this is a losing position because
the King is very weak Group D for ideas
so he goes b3 and now what should we do
now he plays b3 and now this is the
moment where I will take advantage of
his difficult position
you know his knight is stuck and now we
need to try to push now we going for a
serious advantage here but you do need
to find this idea to push his pieces
back and get the complete control of the
center excellent move removing the
active Queen you go see his knight is
not matter and now what do we do
Queen d6 activating the queen bee for
the reason he did that I told you when
you played 95 something bad happened to
his like the night got stuck ish the
night cannot go back and he could simply
lose it
yeah so he had to play the move before
which is not not fun of course but okay
we still have to be alert
we have advantage but it's small it's
not a big advantage so we have to still
try to you know play some good chance to
win this so what to do here
tink tink tink your look is strong on
before but the problem is now it's
getting a little bit you know the
positional book is getting a little bit
loosen so we need to try to do what when
we have a centralized piece we need to
do what guys reinforce it reinforce it
and that's what I did right because if
he captures we capture with the pawn now
open him up now very serious problems
for him so he had to play the mobi 5
what else you can try to do if you opens
up the position is a suicide at least
this way he can be happy as far as not
losing the night because he has a B 3
squared C 6 again go to so now II four I
think this night would really appreciate
this Square and the entrance to the D 3
and if the night which is D 3 the game
is over so this is a kind of move that
you need to try to find in a middle game
that will increase your position look
for this kind of opportunities because
Knight wants to be on d3 but you cannot
really be there unless you play this
precisely
efore ninety five ninety three so that's
why it's a very important idea for you
to do that so e 4 equals here Queen b6
the reason I did that because now I'm
attacking the knight if Knight moves
away I can take on c4 with a check so
I'm forcing him to play this move only
move what else he can do and then I
continued with my move I want to make
him difficult for him to take on d4
because then I go C to X d4 and then
attacking the Queen so it's very
difficult position for it takes C takes
D for so it was can be one
and now
well my d3 work how about this
what is your Roop doing on c8 guys not
too much anymore right so what we gotta
do we gotta bring it in and put pressure
on the rook rook cd8 again this entire
game I don't know if you realize is just
improving the pieces improving the
pieces gradually to their maximum and
now I'm obtaining the file the D file
here because now if he captures he
captures I go C takes d4 now look at
that look at the entire control of D
file now we have well I could 193 but I
figure well he has also 96 so I figured
huh but we loosen up the position now a
six week pawn let's open up his King he
had to do something like this 93 now
comes in if we had gone 93 here he would
have gone 96 why allowed the knight to
come in right let the knight be passive
and we come in if it takes we take C D
now very powerful he plays a four we
take he takes now I went back here this
way now I'm winning his one of the rooks
so he'll be just completely losing if I
take so he took only four now I
mentioned this before in my lecture
since you know if you see when you have
a good move what do we do look for a
better one here Knight X C one is good
no question why it is probably losing
here but when you see something like
this look for a better one and what is
the better one what am i referring to
here Grandmaster move very good
that's a long-range move okay Queen g6
excellent move now attacking the rook
very good job f3 and only then I take he
takes
Group D for it was still not too late to
make a really terrible move like this
and lose the game after rook G for again
we see another poison pawn right same
poison pawn twice in this game remember
the first time you suggested it to take
and now why I suggested this trap I
wanted to show you actually so you could
really lose the game if you play the
wrong move okay so just be aware of that
poison pawn guys don't take pawns
so let's improve the rook we take all
now I took the pawn on g2 because now
his entire pawn structure is weak and
now I'm ready to collect some more pots
the own thing I need to worry about the
past pawn on B file okay but since this
King is week II won't be able to do much
with that so it goes Queen C to check
Queen e1 now completely controlling the
entire position you cannot take on c5
roopd to win it so it goes Quincy
3-letter check activate a little bit
more now if it goes Queen c3 I'm getting
ready to play rook d3 yes sure because
my have a weak pawn on c5 if I lose this
pawn is going to give two connected
passed pawns and I could even lose the
game now I'm still probably winning if I
take and play rook c8 but whose queen is
more active whose King is more week then
why should we exchange Queens right his
king is weak if I had a trivial win yes
I would exchange Queens but then it's
still technical okay it's not trivial to
win so that's why we just we don't have
to you know don't always think the
standard way or over the exchange Queens
if you're ahead
sometime you also have to see what is
going on on the board so it goes here it
really doesn't have moves this is a souk
so on if you place b6 rook b8 is winning
rook b8 was here attack now we increase
our advantage he decided to push what
else you can do slowly but surely I'm
collecting more parts now that is by the
way this doesn't work if
takes I have 24 checkin so he pushed
this one and now I'm pinned so what we
need to do on pin the pin check
and now let's eliminate his last hope
this asset here once we win this last
pawn he is going to be done excellent he
goes here and now what move is important
to play first guys we want to go to p6
but rook b6 allowing 95 so what are you
going to do first check and now
excellent thinking check Ruby 6 and
Grand Master Besser I resigned and this
victory clinch the match for me
because I made it three and half to half
so with a six-game match so the last two
games were drawn so I want to match four
and half to one and half so it was a you
know good result for me okay guys
excellent okay so this was a French
defense game you saw the ideas you know
how after the opening I try to slowly
improve the position try to get an
advantage you know this if you want to
look at this game you can search Becerra
a Cobian game 2014 match game number
four okay but you know this is I think
one a good game one of the recent good
games I've played in a French defense
and just try to you know if a position
was a go but I slowly try to out you
know improve my position to score a win
okay 95 was there yeah yeah I mean it's
it just a match situation was probably
forcing him to play for a win but
basically that's what happened if he had
taken if he had taken on b6 it's very
likely the game would've ended in a draw
I don't have any problem but after 95 it
just became this mix you know where I
was not worse and I slowly outplayed it
him so so identifying was that to keep
the knife over there yeah night on the
rim is them that's the again that's one
more time we saw at a very high level
you know high level game that tier when
you put a knight on the rim you could
in trouble all right great thanks guys
for coming and if you have if you can
make it
please come on Thursday we have a you
know good lectures for Thursday two
lectures so we'll have back in town for
you know a couple of more weeks so we'll
be glad to see okay
thanks for coming
you